let's have some transformation that maps
elements in set x to set y
we know that we call x the domain of t
so that's my set x and then
my set that i'm mapping into set y
that's the codomain we know that t is a
transformation that if you take any
member of x
and you transform it you'll get an or
you'll associate it with a member of set
y you'll map it to a member of set y and
that's what the transformation or the
function does
now if we have some subset of t let's
call a to be some subset of t so let me
draw a like that
this notation right here just means
subset
some subset of d we've defined the
notion of an image
of t of a like that which is
the image
image
of a
of our subset a under
t we've defined this to be equal to the
set
let me write here
the set of all where if we take each of
the members of our subset so if we take
each of the members of our subset
it's the set of all of their
transformations
transformations and of course these are
going to be some subset of y
right there so we essentially take each
of the members of a this was one of them
you find its transformation it's that
point you take another member of a this
is all set a right here take another
member of a find its transformation
maybe it's that point you keep doing
that find its transformation maybe it's
that point and then the set of all of
those transformations maybe it's this
blob right here we call this the image
of a
under t
now what if we wanted to think about the
opposite problem what if we were to
start with set y
which is our co-domain
so that's y and we were to have some
subset of y
let's call it
let's call our subset of y s so s
is a subset of our codomain y
and i'm curious about what subset of x
maps into s
so i'm going i'm curious about this set
i'm i'm curious about the set of all
vectors that are members of my domain
that are members of my domain
such that their mapping or the
transformation of those vectors
ends up in my subset
ends up in my subset of s so what i'm
saying is
look if i take my
my domain
there must be some subset of vectors
right here where if i take any member of
this set it will map into these guys
and that's what i'm defining right here
this is equal to that guy so i'm
literally saying
what is are all of the members of x
where those members of x all map into s
now i want to make a very subtle
notation a subtle i guess nuance here
point out something here i'm not saying
that every point in s necessarily gets
mapped to
for example maybe there's some element
in s right here right there that no
element in x ever gets mapped to from
our transformation t that's okay
all i'm saying is is that everything in
this set maps to something within s
right here and what we call this
we call this set right here we call this
the notation is
the inverse t of s but this is equal to
the pre-image
pre-image of
s
under t
so this is s this is the pre-image
the pre-image of s under t and that
makes sense the image we go from a
subset of our domain to a subset of our
codomain pre-image we go from a subset
of our codomain and we say what subset
of our domain maps into that subset of
our codomain
now let me ask you an interesting
question and this is you know this is
kind of for bonus points
what is the image
of
our
pre image
under s
so what is the image of our pre image
so if we take this guy the image the pre
this is essentially the image of this
guy right here
right
this part right here is the pre-image of
s
right here now if we take the image of
this we're saying what if we take every
member of this
what vectors do they map into all of
them are going to be within s so they're
going to map
within s
but they don't necessarily map to
everything within s
so this is going to be some
subset of s so this right here is going
to be some subset of our original s it's
not necessarily equal to s but it's a
subset of it and so this is i think the
motivation for where the notation comes
from we can construct a subset of s by
taking the image of the pre-image of s
you can kind of view the the image and
the pre-image kind of canceling out and
that's why the inverse notation was
probably introduced now this is all very
abstract what i'm going to do in the
next video is actually calculate or or
determine the pre-image of some subset
of my codomain